[Musique]
bonjour merci de nous rejoindre sur tv
soixante dix huit pour cette nouvelle
édition de votre journal du week-end
nous revenons ensemble sur les
principaux faits et du jour et les
sujets qui ont marqué cette semaine
voici le sommaire un nouveau souffle
pour le centre ville de trappes c'est en
tout cas le souhait de la municipalité
qui vient de signer avec l'état une
nouvelle convention à la clé des
subventions pour les cinq ans à venir
l'université des mairies se tenait cette
semaine à port marly le président du
sénat gérard larcher est venu allait
rencontrer m mais aussi les assurer de
son soutien face aux décisions de l'état
notamment sur la taxe d'habitation et
comme chaque vendredi le point sur
l'actualité de la semaine des principaux
sujets abordés par la rédaction ce sera
en seconde partie de magazines
nous irons aussi avec nos confrères de
via grand paris faire le point sur
l'actualité dans le reste de
l'ile-de-france trappe fait donc
officiellement partie du dispositif
action coeur de ville la commune a signé
ce mardi 9 octobre avec l'état et
l'ensemble de ses partenaires une
nouvelle convention
un document qui a pour objectif d'aider
222 ville en france à hauteur de 5
milliards d'euros pour redynamiser les
centres-villes explications mickaël
millero trappe fait officiellement
partie du dispositif action coeur de
ville la commune a signé ce mardi 9
octobre avec l'état et l'ensemble de ses
partenaires la convention le document a
pour objectif d'aider 222 ville en
france à hauteur de 5 milliards d'euros
pour redynamiser les centres-villes une
ville qui n'a plus de coeur en fait
c'est une ville qui meurt donc on a
besoin d'aider les collectivités d'aider
les partenaires parce que le coeur de la
ville bat à nouveau et bat fort le trap
c'est une ville qui irrigue son bassin
c'est un saint
pôle d'attractivité c'est un fait une
zone de centralité on a de nombreux
équipements sur trappe qui attire autour
du territoire et donc c'est important
que trappe le reste vivante au sein de
ce territoire et que son coeur vive
premiers projets programmés dans le
centre ville de trappes le réaménagement
de l'ancienne auberge de l'étoile d'or
en kafi culture et à 20 g kt et 290 1000
euros quand je sors du cinéma ou ou
jouer quand je sortirai du cinéma jeux
très bien ce serait la place du 8 mai 45
et j'irai prendre un café un thé vert
tôt peu importe
et puis et puis là ce soir là il ya un
groupe qui vient jouer de la musique où
il ya un groupe qui vient faire du
théâtre etc
c'est vraiment un lieu un lieu culturel
que nous nous en avons au mot riziers
nous en avons en pleine love nous n'en
avions pas ici la convention prévoit
également une rénovation de l'habitant
centre-ville dans le secteur de la
mairie et une aide financière pour les
commerçants de la rue jean jaurès et de
ses alentours afin qu'ils puissent
rénover leurs vitrines et à des vitrines
qui sont un petit peu anciennes s'il fut
dirait vraiment c'est par goût du jour
quoi il faudrait innover tout ça que les
commerçants ne puisse pas le faire seul
nous le constatons nous le savons avec
avec ce contrat ils seront aidés dès les
premiers aménagements sont prévus à
partir de début 2019 les travaux
devraient se terminer dans six ans
c'était le rendez vous majeur de la
semaine pour les élus les représentants
à des collectivités l université est des
mairies à port-marly ils étaient près de
1000 à venir échanger lors de tables
rondes ou encore de conférence vous avez
d'ailleurs peut-être suivi notre journée
spéciale sur tv 78 bilan de cet
événement avec grégory canale et nicolas
landry ils se sont rassemblés le temps
d'une journée les maires yvelinois ont
participé ce mercredi 10 octobre à
l'université des mairies des yvelines
des communes urbaines et rurales des
diversité de situations mais une même
inquiétude au fil des ans on nous a
retiré nos compétences les jeunes après
les autres et on nous demande toujours
effectivement encore plus d'efforts avec
moins de moyens je pense que c'est parce
qu'il ya un vrai malaise un malaise par
rapport au maire et par rapport à ce que
l'on vit
avec tout ce que vous savez qu'on répète
régulièrement mais aussi les charges
supplémentaires que l'on nous met sur le
dos voit les responsabilités qu'on nous
met sur le dos donc tout ça fait que eh
bien c'est nécessaire de se retrouver la
commune c'est une petite république dans
la grande île or quand tout va mal c'est
au tour du maire et des élus municipaux
que les citoyens se retrouvent les 262
municipalités yvelinoise peuvent
s'appuyer sur le soutien d'autres
collectivités comme le département ou la
région
nous sommes nos départements déterminer
quoi qu'on veuille faire à rester le
partenaire indispensable de vos communes
et d'être toujours là pour tous vos
besoins
la région intervient notamment en
investissements pour aider les mères à
concrétiser leurs projets mais dans tous
les domaines
donc c'est très important pour moi
d'être au contact avec les maires parce
que c'est eux qui connaissent les
problèmes présents lors de cet événement
les partenaires privés gestion des
déchets de l'énergie ou encore
construction de logements la possibilité
notamment pour le maire de mort pas de
faire le point sur un chantier en cours
dans la zone paris ouest ce projet
d'écoquartier nous le nom avec kaufman
en grande partie c'est une vraie
mutation et donc ont échangé à l'instant
sur ce beau projet puisque le chantier
est en cours et il ya notre 3e une autre
parcelle également muté donc voilà c'est
aussi de partager l'avancée des dossiers
et de s'assurer que tout va bien
l'objectif étant pour la ville de
créer du logement social puisqu'il y
avait un déficit sur sakho mais cette
commune également que for a cure des
nouveaux habitants sur maurepas et
propose un parcours résidentiel au mort
passe bien au jeune morlaisien qui
avaient des difficultés à se loger dans
le parc existant ancien des moments
d'échangé de partage les mairies
yvelinois se donnent rendez vous l'année
prochaine pour une nouvelle édition
et lors de ce rendez-vous à grégory
canal et on a profité pour aller à la
rencontre de gérard larcher le président
du sénat qui et n'hésite pas se
proclamer premier défenseur des élus
locaux
écoutez cet entretien avec gérard
larcher bonjour bonjour président du
sénat avant tout yvelinois pourquoi
c'est un rendez vous important
chaque année pour vous cette université
d'été l'occasion mais nous le ferons
toute l'année de doma je serai toute la
journée avec mes collègues sénateurs
d'un contour de houdan ouais mais
rencontraient les maires et puis
peut-être un peu occasion de faire le
point avec eux pour moi c'était
aujourd'hui l'occasion de faire le point
notamment sur l'ensemble des dispositifs
du logement sujet majeur dans notre
département où les besoins de logements
réel mais où aussi la gestion de la loi
sru et pose parfois des difficultés
inextricables pour les communes
c'est une yvelinoise qui préside la
commission des affaires économiques
sophie primas qui dans un dialogue avec
l'assemblée nationale avec des
rapporteurs a permis un certain nombre
d'avancées notamment on remet le maire
au centre des grandes opérations
d'urbanisme
on traitera certain nombre de sujets qui
n'étaient pas traités notamment sur
l'habitat insalubre sur l'expulsion des
squats aussi et enfin sur la loi sru on
sort du carcan pour les communes hors de
l'unité urbaine de paris de cette
fameuse seuil de 1500 habitants qui
était un casse-tête à guerville ou à son
chant
c'était un vrai casse tête on sait que
le sénat un rôle de représentation des
collectivités locales de ces communes
c'est votre voix vous la fait entendre
au niveau national je crois savoir qu on
la fait entendre et même que les écouter
d'autant plus que les relations entre
les territoires à l'exécutif sont des
relations difficiles et je le disais il
ya un instant devant mes collègues
maires on doit être aussi ceux qui
permettent aux mains de stand ea vers
les autres pour apporter des réponses
aux collectivités territoriales baisse
des dotations
ça va faire maintenant la septième année
des contraintes extrêmement élevé une
responsabilité des maires nous
présenteront demain nos propositions en
matière de statut de l'élu
c'est la délégation collectivités
locales présidé par un élu alsacien jean
marie bockel ancien ministre qui le fera
et à la fin du mois de vraies
propositions pour permettre de sortir du
blocage d'un certain nombre
d'intercommunalités de trop grande
taille qui sont paralysés
voilà c'est un échelon communal qui est
menacée vous l'avez dit baisse des
dotations de l'état pourquoi il faut le
défendre vous avez été maire vous
notamment de la commune à rambouillet
parce que c'est le coeur de la
république quelle que soit la taille la
commune c'est une petite république dans
la grande et or quand tout va mal c'est
au tour du maire et des élus municipaux
que les citoyens se retrouvent
on peut imaginer des organisations
nouvelle moi j'étais favorable de la loi
chevènement en intercommunalité je le
demeure mais ça peut pas être dans la
disparition de la commune qui a des
formes nouvelles d'organisation c'est
qu'ils ne sont pas faciles à mettre en
place dans le département et que dans le
grand ouest elle rencontre un grand
succès c'est les communes nouvelles
il faut être prêt il faut avoir le désir
faut avoir envie vous que ça parte de la
base nous ne savions pas du sommet
dernière session sort juste de cette
université des maires sur les
difficultés de la création d'un nouveau
gouvernement le voit actuellement qu'est
ce que ça vous inspire
écoutez ça appartient au président de
république voiture gaulliste c'est donc
le président de la république
décide de la composition du gouvernement
ensuite l'assemblée nationale aura
peut-être à dire la confiance si le
premier ministre démissionne moi je
pense qu' il serait utile qu'il repasse
par la case confiance parce que je sors
beaucoup de défiance dans le pays merci
à gérard larcher président du sénat
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions
depuis les universités des mairies ici à
port marly
[Musique]
lors de chaque hebdo nous ouvrons les
archives de tv 78 les sujets qui ont
fait l'actualité locale nous remontons
le temps cette fois ci pour faire escale
le 3 octobre 2000 vous allez voir que
les problèmes de circulation à saint
quentin en yvelines ne date pas d'hier
alors que le ton monte aujourd'hui entre
les élus de magny les hameaux et de
voisins-le-bretonneux pour savoir où
faire passer les véhicules leurs
prédécesseurs étaient déjà confrontés à
ce problème
en cause une voix a le cv 7 qui relie
montigny le bretonneux à magny les
hameaux pour des raisons de sécurité le
maire de l'époque nicolas abou maire de
montigny ferme la circulation elle ne
sera finalement ouverte que dans un sens
des années plus tard
cette petite route de campagne au coeur
de la polémique entre magny les hameaux
et montigny le bretonneux baptisé cv cet
autrement dit chemin vicinal sa vocation
première était rurale et agricole
depuis quelques temps le trafic
automobile s'est intensifiée et cette
route qui relie les deux communes sert
de raccourci pour atteindre la ville
nouvelle colère de nicolas abou qui
décide avant l'été de fermer le c 17
on voit bien que c'est complètement
insupportable quand on sait qu on a 1000
élèves au collège saint françois
d'assise et qui est juste à l'angle on à
l'école daudet on a le collège de la
couldre avec encore cinq cents élèves on
voit bien que on ne peut pas dévier le
trafic d'une départementale par un
chemin rural et l'amener en pleine zone
urbaine danse chant qui est des risques
majeurs pour tout le monde
un comptage des voitures est alors
organisé début septembre 2500 véhicules
empruntent chaque jour le cv 7 60 %
viennent de magny-les-hameaux un quart
de la vallée de chevreuse la fer se
poursuit en préfecture avec une première
réunion de conciliation
le préfet a fait savoir que la fermeture
ne se justifiaient justifiait pas il y
avait besoin encore de travailler
j'ai fait moi savoir que de toute
évidence les promus situation existait
sur toutes les communes et que bien
évidemment s'il fallait chercher c'est à
fluidifier situation et certaines pas
donc fermé des fois quand on amène le
bordel chez les autres on est gêné quand
on ne peut plus le faire mais c'est tout
mais donc ma position c'est que une fois
pas contents de pouvoir mettre la
panique chez nous ne me touche
absolument pas c'est ça fait un peu fou
tu meurs mais la solution pour une
commune lorsqu'on est problèmes liés à
ces pendant qu'on a créé en plus
pressante en créant les aménagements
qu'ils sont je ne critique pas il ya
elias à succès tant mieux pour la
commune de mancini mais c'est pas en
fermant la porte aux autres que les jo
serait long nous avons des vitesses
excessives nous avons le stock n'est
jamais respectée devant safran soit
jamais et en plus on observe que du côté
voisins la voie e de sud qui est là
prolongement du cdh et du célé 91
évident
donc nous ne comprenons pas pourquoi on
veut absolument nous faire supporter un
tel trafic et de tels risques
alors qu'il ya une voie qui a été fait
pour ça qui n'est pas utilisé troisième
protagoniste le maire de voisins
contacté par la rédaction qui préfère ne
pas répondre avant la deuxième réunion
de conciliation prévue mi-octobre dans
le bureau du préfet en attendant le cv 7
sera fermée à la fin du mois pour des
travaux programmée de longue date
[Musique]
on passe au résumé de la semaine avec
tout d'abord le premier salon de la
parentalité du bien-être avoir un enfant
est une étape importante dans une vie
mais aussi un bouleversement pour les
parents ce salon devait répondre aux
inquiétudes chant prénatal coach pour
parents réflexologie sophrologie telles
étaient les stands présents à l'occasion
du premier salon de la parentalité du
bien-être à trappes
il est organisé par à cali l'association
des créateurs de lien inter
générationnel en collaboration avec
saint quentin en yvelines
le parent parfait n'existe pas mais par
contre le parent est tous les jours
confronté à des questionnements des
doutes des difficultés des joies des
peines qui le confronte à ses propres
limites et du coup savoir qu'il peut
comme on dire être soutenu dans ses
actions au quotidien avec ses enfants et
bien
ça peut être très aidant pour lui encore
faut-il qu'ils sachent vers qui se
retourner d'où l'utilité de ce salon
pour nous faire connaître auprès but
lors de ce salon d'hiver professionnels
de soutien à la parentalité du bien-être
sont présents pour répondre aux
difficultés et questions des parents
c'est plutôt vraiment revoir
qu'est-ce que dans le qu'est ce que moi
je fais qui a une incidence sur le
comportement de l'enfant est ce que je
suis pas en train d'empirer la situation
quand l'enfant vit des difficultés et
donc qu'est-ce que je peux faire - en
tant qu'adulte pour améliorer la
relation et surtout le comportement
finalement l'enfant dans des ateliers
étaient organisés afin de permettre une
découverte concrète de certaines
techniques ou pratiques
l'idée c'est de rentrer en communication
avec son enfant déjà in utero j'ai
ensuite quand il est né et plus tard
quand il grandit en fait via la musique
et le toucher l'association à cali
espère pouvoir renouveler cette
expérience l'année prochaine avec un
deuxième salon la semaine bleue
intercommunal des seniors vient de se
tenir pour l encours maurepas et
coignières à cette occasion une
animation à la salle des fêtes de
maurepas sur le thème de la sécurité
routière a été proposé aux plus de 65
ans avec l'âge et malgré une longue
expérience de la conduite le taux de
mortalité des seniors a augmenté de 18%
reportage manon varaldo avec l'avancée
de l'âge il est important de rappeler
certaines règles sur les dangers de la
route
les seniors ont participé à divers
ateliers simulateurs de voitures
actualisation des connaissances du code
de la route gestes qui sauvent ou encore
parcours lunettes alcool on est vraiment
très mal
je n'ai pas bu je ne bois pas
régulièrement et j'avais l'impression
d'être sur un bateau des pompiers des
spécialistes de la police nationale et
de la sécurité routière ont échangé avec
les seniors l'ambiance était détendue
pourtant l'enjeu était de taille
véhiculer des messages adaptés aux
seniors de plus en plus touchés la taux
de mortalité sur la route chez les
seniors a fortement augmenté dans le
département ces dernières années on est
passé à +18 % en quelques années et
surtout pour les plus de 75 ans les
responsables de la sécurité routière
souhaite sensibiliser les seniors sur
leur capacité à prévenir d'éventuelles
difficultés
on a eu beaucoup d'accidents de
seigneurs piétons sont les accidents ou
en fait un senior s'était engagé sur la
chaussée n'a pas fait attention un poids
lourd et s'est retrouvé dans l'angle
mort du poids lourds et le poids lourd
l'a écrasée du coup ça c'est un message
à faire passer effectivement dire aux
piétons pas qu'aux seniors
attention au poids lourds ils n'ont pas
les mêmes champs de vision qu'une
automobile et donc ils peuvent ne pas
vous voir quand vous êtes sur la
chaussée cette action originale a retenu
l'attention des principaux intéressés
une cinquantaine de personnes étaient
présentes
je trouve que c'est très intéressant
parce que quand on vieillit on n'est pas
aux dernières nouvelles au point de vue
code de la route surtout au point de vue
performances ça fait du bien de se
remettre en question des informations
complémentaires sur les dangers de la
route sont à retrouver sur le site
internet de la sécurité routière du
sport avec du cyclisme sur piste la
fédération française a dévoilé jeudi
dernier les pistards qui vont participer
à la coupe du monde au vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
les 19 20 et 21 octobre prochains
les spectateurs pourront voir sur la
piste les multiples champions du monde
françois pervis grégory baugé ou encore
la future pépite mathilde gros reportage
michael et demi d'euros patrick jacques
de dixmude les pistards de l'équipe de
france était sous les feux des
projecteurs ce jeudi 4 octobre
la fédération a dévoilé officiellement
les noms des sportifs qui participeront
à l'étape de coupe du monde organisée du
19 au 21 octobre et l'autre national de
saint quentin en yvelines
vous pouvez voir dans l'équipe de france
il ya des coureurs expérimentés qui ont
déjà participé à plusieurs jeux
olympiques plusieurs champions du monde
et puis des jeunes donc ça c'est
également vrai en endurance notamment
chez les filles
donc on doit et de scorer dans toutes
les disciplines ski ce qui est possible
dans les anciens l'autre alors au tour
de grégory baugé neuf fois champion du
monde et la présence de ligne montrent
un françois pervis cette fois couronné
au niveau mondial ce dernier nourrit de
grandes ambitions sur cette compétition
à 33 ans il faut pas se louper puisque
dans deux ans il va falloir avoir assez
de points pour avoir tous les quotas au
niveau de déchets olympique donc c'est
très important
la nouvelle génération sera quant à elle
symbolisé par deux visages sébastien
vigier 21 ans et mathilde de gros 19 ans
ses dernières va endosser le rôle de
favorite sur cette compétition à
domicile après un titre européen cet été
c'est énorme pour moi ça va être la
première fois que je vis une grosse
compétition ici à domicile donc voilà va
falloir essayer de ne pas trop se mettre
la pression ça va être une chose
nouvelle pour moi on va voir comment je
réagis j'espère que ça se passera bien
et j'espère que je donne enfin que tout
cas j'aurai une belle médaille pour mes
amis et ma famille cette équipe de
france devrait se produire devant plus
de dix mille spectateurs sur ces trois
jours de compétition vélodrome national
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines toujours en
tête des meilleures ventes de livres la
romancière amélie nothomb aime aller à
la rencontre de ses lecteurs et
lectrices mercredi soir elle était à la
librairie et le pavé du canal à montigny
le bretonneux 2
nombreux fans yvelinois ont fait le
déplacement après l'émotion du livre
l'émotion de la rencontre amélie nothomb
écrit un livre par an depuis 1992 des
romans toujours très attendu par ses
fans
cette vendéenne fait ses études à
l'université versailles saint quentin
elle attend d'ailleurs de rencontrer son
auteur préféré depuis longtemps pour
l'occasion elle lui a même écrit une
lettre
c'est vraiment quelque chose de très
touchant elle prend le temps de
comprendre de nous appeler par nos
prénoms ça se voit que c'est pas du tout
mécanique
c'est vraiment une très belle personne
et il fait de très beau livre donc pour
tous ceux qui la connaissent pas il faut
connaître mais les notes sont tous
apprécient son univers original et son
écriture soignée ils étaient nombreux à
patienter pour une dédicace et quelques
minutes des changes avec l'auteur
tout d'abord c'est parfaitement écrit
une fois qu'il maîtrise parfaitement la
langue française a pas fait des études
de philologie pour rien et puis c'est un
pur bonheur allait super elle est
adorable et très
très proches visiblement de ses lecteurs
et c'est très agréable
une rencontre tout aussi apprécié de
l'autre côté de la table
amélie nothomb n'était pas revenu à
saint quentin en yvelines depuis trois
ans elle ya trouvé un accueil très
chaleureux
vous savez quand on écrit et quand on
écrit au degré où j'écris on est
terriblement seul forcément et on ne
sait pas si ce qu'on écrit à un sens est
aussi encore moins qui se cachent de
l'autre côté du papier alors le moment
où l'on découvre c'est le moment de
vérité maintenant c'est vraiment on
découvre qu'ils se cachent de l'autre
côté du papier croyez moi c'est
bouleversant son dernier roman les
prénoms dépit scène est sorti le 22 août
dernier et s'est classé directement en
tête des ventes de la rentrée littéraire
et puisque l'on parle littérature
évoquons le prix goncourt l'un des plus
prestigieux prix remis en france un prix
et qui se décline maintenant à
destination des lycéens depuis 1988 des
élèves âgés de 15 à 18 ans lise étudi
ait des ouvrages sélectionnés cette
année c'est une classe de seconde du
lycée de la plaine 2 nov la trappe qui
fait partie du jury
marylène ya piché dans
[Musique]
car au nom plus de 4000 pages à lire en
deux mois cette seconde du lycée de la
plaine de neauphle ne chôme pas depuis
la rentrée elle participe au prix
goncourt des lycéens avec leur
professeur de lettres
pour une fois la lecture ça sort du
cadre scolaire de la lecture analytique
de l'élection linéaire des commentaires
proposés tout ça c'est autre chose
l'idée c'est de ses de retrouver une
forme de liberté par rapport au livre
parce que parce que souvent il est vécue
dans la scolarité comme étant une forme
de contrainte
le 15 novembre un lauréat recevra le
prix avant il faut lire découvert de
nouvelles techniques des lectures et
échanges avec leurs professeurs et
organisations de l'emploi du temps puis
sur ton mercredi après midi parce qu'on
a on n'a pas cours le samedi aussi
dimanche du cousin promeut week-end et
c'est pas grave c'est qu'on aura fini
bon on sera content je me suis relié
avec eux mon nom mon camarade en groupe
de deux ans on dit un des livres les
quinze livre qu'on lit pas comme si on
lisait un livre normalement en fait on y
on y vite et on saute d on peut sauter
des paragraphes ou des passages d'une
des pages pour les aider dans leurs
choix les 30 trappistes on peut
rencontrer les auteurs durant une
journée sur paris ils ont pu poser des
questions lors de conférences d'enrichir
ma culture déjà le savoir aussi du coup
quand je lis un livre je me poserai
différentes questions des questions que
j'ai pas forcé que me suis pas forcément
posée avant j'ai trouvé ça intéressant
parce qu'on pouvait voir leurs esprits
en fait ce qu'ils pensaient vraiment en
écrivant leurs livres et c'était
intéressant de jouer ça n'a rien à voir
avec les rencontres avec les adultes ils
sont beaucoup plus coûteux
il est vraiment ce qu'ils pensent encore
un mois de lectures avant de devoir
faire un choix avec le prix goncourt des
lycéens certains élèves ont renforcé
leur amour de la lecture d'autres l'ont
découvert
il
chaque semaine nos confrères devient
grand paris ils reviennent sur
l'actualité en ile-de-france aujourd'hui
focus sur la course aux municipales qui
s'engagent aussi à paris et l'heure du
bilan pour anne hidalgo à un an et demi
des municipales à paris anne hidalgo
commence à faire le bilan de son mandat
dans son livre respirer sur la pollution
le premier acte force jouant nous 2016
les voies sur berge devienne piétonne
est interdite à la circulation
applaudissements des écolos colère des
associations d'automobilistes
le bilan reste mitigé selon un rapport
des repas riffs sur les 3 km 5 de kéba
la qualité de l'air s'améliore la
pollution s'aggrave sur les carrefours
des quais hauts et sur les itinéraires
de report autres pistes pour rendre
l'air plus respirable dans la capitale
elle est radicale retirer de la
circulation les véhicules polluants la
maire de paris précise son calendrier
fin du diesel à paris en 2024
ça sera 2030 pour les véhicules
thermiques
même si lui ne pollue pas il s'est fait
attendre des parisiens premier trimestre
2010 8 déploiement raté pour le nouveau
vélib la promesse d'un tiers de vélos à
assistance électrique à séduisante mais
faut-il encore les trouver avant l'été
anne hidalgo haussent le ton la
résiliation du contrat avec le nouveau
prestataire est envisagée en septembre
la situation s'améliore
823 stations sont aujourd'hui
opérationnels loin encore des 1200
annoncé sur le territoire de la
métropole du grand paris autre dossier
qui polluent l'été de la maire de paris
les autolib électrique rentrer au garage
en juillet dernier la mairie résilie son
contrat avec bolloré après 12 ans de
service mais la voiture en libre service
à paris n'est pas morte solution de
rechange l'auto partage avec de nouveaux
opérateurs privés mais qui dit voiture
même partagé dit pollution
et si la solution c'était les transports
gratuits pour tous à paris c'est le
nouveau sujet de débat lancé par anne
hidalgo la maire de paris a commandé un
rapport à trois de ses adjoints
c'est la fin de cet hebdo au retour du
journal lundi à 18 heures avec grégory
canal et vous pouvez aussi suivre
l'actualité sur notre site internet
notre application
bill et sur les réseaux sociaux très bon
week end
[Musique]